here
ladies and gentlemen dear colleagues
good afternoon this session is
it
has been agreed to change the agenda and
to add items
the deadline has been moved after the Q
a upon the request
of CDU CSU
an additional session has been asked for
on Thursday after item
um
make the item 18 is supposed to be
called item seven as well as 11 to 13
will be moved and item seven
will and now
have a debating time of
39 minutes and other items will be
changed accordingly item 15 is removed
on Friday the session will
it start at 11 30.
first item on the agenda is several
submissions on changing the electoral
system will be called
item 19 will be removed and ultimately I
would like to refer you to the annex
I don't see any objections
it has thus been decided I am now I
start with a agenda item one the federal
government has announced that the
chancellor Mr Olaf Charles is available
a Chancellor you have the floor
ladies and gentlemen
I'm very pleased to be able to answer
your questions today I would like to
make some preliminary comments before I
came here I spoke to president zielinski
discussed the current situation and also
what Germany is doing and will be doing
ladies and gentlemen if we hear
the concerns and worries over the last
year and if we recall everything that's
happened
foreign
that
there will be an economic crisis there
will be bottlenecks during the winter
there will be all the challenges that we
are facing some people
um have talked about an Autumn of rage
and a winter of Rage that we would be
living through in this country the truth
is that this hasn't happened we are
sitting here it's warm in here and we
have energy available across a Germany
we have new infrastructure and we've
made sure that the economic power of our
country can be maintained and we have
also a brought the costs of energy down
with
relevant support measures by the
government
president
so one can say the federal government
has managed to control the crisis the
report today has shown that the
situation in the country has improved
and we've also shown what we can do and
that is very important to me
within a very short space of time we
implemented all the measures necessary
using a nuclear plants longer using coal
again and getting a gas from a different
airports and new terminals in Northern
Germany the first three
and have already received trips and that
is a good sign for Germany
at this stage I would like to say that
the speed with which we've acted is the
speed that we need right across the
country we in need to make sure that we
secure the future and looking at the
crisis and the fight against the crisis
we've seen that we can be successful
using renewable energy using solar
energy wind power
and transforming industry to make sure
that we can achieve what we have planned
and that is to First the CO2 a neutral
country in the world we want to show
that it is possible and in doing so we
want to encourage others to follow us on
this path
we
so respect before the citizens with all
the measures that we have implemented
ladies and gentlemen
reason for the challenges we are facing
is the terrible war of aggression of
Russia against the Ukraine a terrible
War where the principles that we have
agreed upon in Europe has been called
into question the principles that
included that borders must not be
changed by the use of force this is what
a Russia is doing and this is what I
have discussed with you in Parliament on
previous occasion when we discussed that
times have changed
and because of that it is right that in
close cooperation with our International
Partners we support Ukraine financially
with humanitarian means but also by
supplying arms
we had to break with what we've been
doing in Germany for decades and we and
Great Britain are the countries in
Europe that provide most arms to Ukraine
we have taken many decisions already and
we can say that Germany will always be
upfront when it comes to supporting
Ukraine we are the country that provides
the great deal of health and support
we have decided that we also want to
deliver heavy Armory
artillery we have made a part available
then EST a defense system new rockets
have been delivered we will deliver
further system the Patriot system
um we've decided within government to
deliver that all these are measures to
make sure that Ukraine can defend
herself and we have taken all these
decisions in close corporations with our
allies that because of that these
decisions are effective that is the
principle that this government is
working
and we will continue to do that there
has been a decision recently to deliver
Bradley
um and we provide Marda as um
our personnel carriers and we have war
in Europe not a very far from here and
there is war against
Ukraine as such a big country and one
thing has to be clear we will do what is
necessary what is possible to support
Ukraine but at the same time we want to
make sure that there's no escalation of
the war between Russia and nature and he
will cling to this principle also in
future
in doing so
um there are no mathematical certainties
nobody really knows where the right and
the wrong decisions are exactly and this
is why we have worked through this bit
by bit step by step and we will continue
to do that also in future that is the
only principle that provides a safety
before Europe and also for Germany in
future in these difficult times
[Applause]
and that is also true for the most
recent decision that the government has
taken we will
also deliver battle tanks to Ukraine
leopard two tanks that is the result of
a very a close and intense discussions
with our partners with our allies and I
want to say clearly it is important that
we have close cooperation in this matter
and that we continue with this
cooperation
our aim is
to deliver two tank battalions together
with our allies there are many countries
that want to join in we will coordinate
it and include these countries so this
will become possible step by step
Germany will make available if our 2r6
thanks
from the Army inventories in Germany and
we will train Ukrainian Crews here we
will make a logistics available
replenishment and we will also allow
partner countries to deliver these tanks
ladies and gentlemen this is the right
principle we are talking about very
effective systems and it is right that
we never
make them available on our own but in
close cooperation with others one final
word there are many citizens in this
country that are worried worried
because of this decision and the
dimensions that this type of arm
brings about please trust us trust the
government we will continue working at
an international level we have made the
support possible without
the risks increasing into the wrong
direction this is because we have worked
together and we will continue to do so
work with our own
thank you very much for these
introductory comments and if you also
treated me when we have the next session
like this I would be very grateful to
you we now start with questions to the
chancellor
the floor has jurgenhard from CDU CSU
Assessor
present of parliament Chancellor you um
announced it to the Dress would have
welcomed it being announced here so that
we would have been able to discuss it
but be that as it may it has been the
right decision and it is important that
sometimes we can change our thinking at
this stage I would like to point out
that on coming to this decision a lot of
damage has been done only a few days ago
there were arguments with a government
from other countries uh Poland after for
the permission yesterday I didn't get
the clear yes yesterday
in its speech at this both of you spoke
is that one is not only measured by the
decision one takes but also by the
decisions one doesn't take and so there
has been a lot of damage reputation for
Germany who's responsible for that thank
you very much for your question and also
for the opportunity to talk at length
about the subject I'm of a completely
different opinion and we've made the
decision today we announced a decision
today and I've used the first
opportunity to come here to Parliament
and say something to the God because it
is important for all of us and it is
right to do so and come to Thailand
but I would also like to say quite
clearly if we had followed your Council
it would be a danger for the safety of
Germany
many citizens are afraid that they are
governed the way that you are intending
together it would be a mistake a very
severe mistake to take a unilateral
decision it is important to work in
concert with others and it is a very
clear that not the next press
announcement is the calendar by which we
work but by coordination with our
friends and our allies this is what we
need to do if we want to secure
Peace and Freedom for Europe
and if you want to help you train
you're allowed to ask a follow-on
question
Chancellor you spoke about
not wanting to provoke Russia when
supporting Ukraine in order not to enter
into a war between Russia and NATO
um
yes we are now
supplying uh tanks now you're saying it
is no longer a provocation but you
considered it a provocation last year
well I did not speak about provocation
if there is provocation and then it's
provocation on behalf of Russia they are
attacking the Ukraine in order to gain
territory
but let me say quite clearly what the
difference is if anybody
really believes
that it were right
to
not coordinate with others that one does
not take the first and the second and
the third step at the right time then it
wouldn't be good for Peace and Freedom
in Europe we have worked very closely
with our strongest friends and allies
and we will continue to do so in future
another question
from Mr Han cgu CSU thank you very much
president
Chancellor
almost a year ago
you talked about the times are changing
and you announced to support
um the
military with a hundred million and
nothing has been paid yet there is high
inflation there are high interest rates
and the two percent are not in the
current budget nor in the planning and
you also said that Germany should take
on leadership and we should become the
strongest army in Europe I'm asking
myself for when what do you want to make
good on your word and obviously be
welcome at what you've said but we need
to now take the necessary steps yes um
I said what I said in Parliament
immediately after the war started
against the Ukraine and we took
decisions together we have a clear
requirements of making two percent
available for defense and I affirmed
that I want to stick with that and I
want to make sure not just in this
period but in the following periods and
we have provided the foundation to bring
about the rider infra structure
Islands and we will continue to take the
right decisions what we need are
concrete decisions for some concrete
systems some decisions have already been
taken as regards the F-35 as regards a
helicopter other decisions are imminent
and obviously we will be entering into
long-term contracts until production
takes place also as regards ammunition
and spare parts and we need to remove
the mistakes that have been made in the
past that defense Ministers of a cduses
you have committed not as they're just a
half in the military and they're doing
away with conscription it's also the
biggest austerity measures under
conservative politicians and it also
includes that we correct all the
mistakes that have been made no
long-term contracts and and the fact
that we don't have enough they are part
of the long term that we do not have
enough ammunition because it's no longer
produced these mistakes have been made
now we need to work very closely with a
military Chancellor please
and might appeal to all of you please
stick to the times allotted
that also applies to you Chancellor the
next question
from a witness noise the greens anesh
thank you very much president
Chancellor it is the right decision that
the cabinet has taken
the decision to deliver the part thanks
and particularly when we look at the
fact that innocent people in the Ukraine
are suffering from the crimes of War
committed by Russia and that there is a
big offensive imminent and the federal
federal government makes an important
contribution
and
we've discussed it over the last weeks
and months and these debates have shown
that you have the support of parliament
leopard A1 is supposed to be delivered
from a industry inventories then a
leopard to A6 from uh Army inventories I
welcome it it is a strong sign it is
important what made you take that
decision thank you very much for your
question we have decided
um to use what we have available it's
been carefully prepared and what we've
decided here today and obviously our
partners for a number of weeks and
months have been prepared and obviously
um
the calendar is not a governed by what's
happening in Germany when we look to
other countries so it's important that
we've done what we've done here
and now we will try to make sure that we
make available the first Battalion on a
very high level and then
um when it comes to leopard B it might
then make earlier systems available so
that they're taken all together will be
very effective you may ask a follow-on
question thank you yes obviously it is a
serious questions that need to be
answered and I think we are all very
serious about it the public debate is
very much about delivering arms but when
it comes to our solidarity and support
to Ukraine it's not just based on the
delivery of a weaponry and arms will
though that is very necessary so where
do you see the biggest requirements the
biggest need of what people from the
Ukraine will continue to need from us
and from the West well fully agree with
you we will support the Ukraine with the
weapons along as that is possible at the
same time we will do everything possible
that financially and on a humanitarian
level we make Aid available we've done
it in the past uh Germany has given
billions last year and we will continue
to do so obviously we want to need to
secure the energy infrastructure
the Intolerable
a bombardment of energy infrastructure
um has been carried out by Russia we
need to help to rebuild the
infrastructure and at the same time we
are starting to think about the
Reconstruction of Ukraine because we are
hoping
um for this war to end that the Ukraine
can defend its sovereignty but then it
will take years and decades during which
the world Community needs to support
Ukraine in reconstructing the country
and so we have started to establish
structures that we can also and already
start working towards that
from afd
Germany thank you very much Madam
president dear colleagues Chancellor
um you
can
feel it
that it is an historic day you have
thrown overboard the principles that
we've had after the second World War
and
first and foremost it was about six
million Jews and 20 millions of women
men and children that were killed in the
Soviet Union and your
greatest Social Democratic predecessors
and Billy brand worked towards
reconciliation William brunt and
received the
um Nobel Prize for Peace no more war no
weapons in to
um more theaters is what Germany did
after the war these were principles
strong principles in Germany
thank you very much colleague I agree
with you never again Fascism and he's
aware the principles and if you continue
shouting you're not worth being here and
having this discussion please let the
colleague ask his question because his
time is running out and plays a focus on
this q a Madam president I hope that
you're not deducting the time
for these interruptions from my time
well Chancellor you will be entering
into history as the chancellor that has
a trampled this Heritage underfoot and
millions of people in this country are
asking why are you doing this why have
you done this why have you broken with
your electoral promises why are you
turning yourself against the majority of
the citizens in this country I think and
and if you say it's in order to agree
and sorry it's up to charge the
chancellor to reply now you can come
back to your question but it's down to
the chancellor now thank you very much
for your question let me give you a
clear answer yes it breaks with all of
these great political achievements that
uh um
[Applause]
a result of your politics which you are
core politics of a Deton where
negotiations about uh that he joined a
security cooperation in Europe as an
ultimate a goal and
um
Also regarding democracy but I'm
focusing on a different aspect it also
included a clear statement that
orders will not be changed by violence
Russia's war of aggression is an
imperialistic War
and
um okay I might have gone through
um history books that uh tell me once
upon a time those borders were different
and because of that I now have the right
to destroy and a a country in order to
get these borders back and that is
against the principles
you're allowed to ask a follow-on
question of course you're right
Chancellor it is imperialistic as is the
extension of NATO
if we are quoting
um millibrant and helmwood Schmidt we
should also stick with not enlarging
NATO but you said you want to support
Ukraine as long as necessary how are you
defining this so what are the aims of
War when will you stop delivering arms
we talked about a five thousand the
helmets now we're talking about a
tanks and aircraft we're not talking
about aircraft I'm not sure why you
mentioned aircraft and if you see that
somewhere please let me know in order to
be quite clear we are making
wide-ranging support available so that
Ukraine can defend its integrity and
sovereignty the
aim
of Russia
is a two conquer part of the territory
and this is what differentiates us
um we feel that one country is not the
backyard of another Russia must not say
we can decide what we want it to do and
this imperialistic idea that Putin can
govern in Ukraine is what led him to
this war and we are refuting that and
this is why we are providing support for
Ukraine
I understand next question Dr Marie
under structiverman from the fpd
delivery
Chancellor
at
was very good news that has been
confirmed today that the government are
now Paving the way to send tanks to
Ukraine it's also good news for the
people in Ukraine and as you said
they have been violated for the last 11
months and I would like to congratulate
our new defense secretary we had a
chance to have a good Exchange in the
committee
counselor you rightly spoke of a
large-scale Alliance us Germans are part
of EU part of NATO perhaps you could be
a little bit more concrete as to who
works closely together with us and
whether our countries that might need a
little bit more persuasion because
there's so many different countries in
different countries in this large
Alliance and perhaps that might improve
operation in future many thanks for that
question first of all I can say what we
are doing is a based on what has been
done in the past all important decisions
um
as regards
um the um how it's uh the multiple
launch rocket system is he and also a
little a while ago regarding patreon and
murder were taken
with our most important allies in
Northern America and here in Europe with
these allies acting along the same lines
and because of that it is important to
invest time in order to bring about a
coordination and obviously in each
country needs to then
address themselves to their own country
and I don't want to
um
speak for them but it is important that
we cooperate together that we work
closely together and
it is important that we are discussing
these things
means that we need to make our
contribution and this is what we're
willing to do
you're allowed to ask a following
question well yes we are of the opinion
that that too is uh is good news
question mark that we are part of the
alliance and that other partners will
then follow us in the next months and so
that they will also follow us in
supporting Ukraine in terms of financial
aid humanitarian Aid yes we will
continue to work on that and obviously
um we will allow our partners should
they want to do so Supply
um the tanks where we need to give
permission and obviously we want to make
sure that we are bundling forces so that
we can also make sure it's ammunition
and supplies are being made available it
is
thank you very much Madam president
Chancellor please allow me to change
the subject matter
obviously the Russian attack against the
Ukraine needs us all but I have a
question regarding pensions
a subject that moves many people in this
country even if it is not about life and
death a Chancellor I have noted with a
pleasure of what you said in September
in Essen that you
want during a dis a period
bring about a fiscal solution when it
comes to estate pensions the company
pensions and linked with the health
insurance contribution so please
confirm it here and please let us know
when and how are you planning to bring
about a solution to this problem thank
you very much you're right into the
subject of interest to many citizens and
because of that we have
worked on it as the Coalition it is an
important mandate and we are still very
much considering how we bring a solution
about obviously it is something that we
are planning to work on and I can assure
you that we will be providing a solution
not allowed to ask a follow-on question
yes thank you very much and thank you
also for your answer so are there
already any concrete steps any
books with the relevant ministers is
there already a schedule and
are you also considering to stop
multiple contributions and perhaps pay
compensation to people that had to make
contributions through
um a different uh contributors when it
comes to a Company pension so to
restricted to the contribution of the
employers
well
during the last parliamentary period we
already brought about improvements for
um
some of the people obviously it is not
easy and because of that we first of all
concentrated what are we doing with the
people that are currently
um receiving pensions and and then we
obviously also need to they're currently
about to receive their pensions but then
we also need to look into those that
already are in receipt of their pension
next question please
um Madam president Chancellor first of
all
on behalf of many people here I would
like to thank you for the decision thank
you very much for coming here and
talking to us about that decision
to deliver tanks and arms you made it
clear that
we have some clear principles as to how
we proceed together with the Allies by
taking into consideration the risks and
in a full support of sovereignty of
Ukraine unfortunately over the last few
days we read various rumors regarding
the U.S German relations would you
perhaps say something on how you're
coordinating with the US not as regards
the concrete
deliveries of weapons perhaps you could
say something about the relationship
thank you very much for your question I
can tell you that the relationship
between Germany and the US are on a a
very good level as as good as not for a
long time or has been the case for a
long time
um the American president is I think a
very a capable a person that takes good
decisions
in international
Arenas and
for him it is important to a worker as
part of the Trans-Atlantic Alliance and
is a very good partner for us for
Germany so my conversations with the
president are always a very friendly
I read something about talks that have
been conducted by others but
um
that's
not a really what what I can confirm I
can confirm we've had very friendly
talks you're allowed to follow on
questions
well the most important Ally within
Europe is France there's very close
coordination with the French government
when it comes to supporting Ukraine
what's the weather view to Ukraine uh
joining EU over the weekend the mystery
Council met can you tell us something
about the joint support for Ukraine yes
of course we talked about the question
and we are agreed that we will continue
to support Ukraine with everything the
necessary also with a financial and a
humanitarian Aid you've seen that
last time
um
Germany and the US Republican
supported Ukraine models at the same
time and we are also agreed with France
that we wanted to act jointly next
question about Fallen
thank you very much Madam president
for me there is one problem
and
that is on Twitter Mr Melnick and I
quote with your permission and now dear
allies
let us put together a strong fighter jet
a campaign for Ukraine
with um tornadoes that are 15 and quite
the Jets and everything that you can
supply to Ukraine my question is if uh
then calls to provide ground troops that
we need to say no at some point because
we come to a point when we say that's
not part and parcel of supporting a
country in its defense and yesterday in
the Council of Europe and we heard we
have we are fighting a fight against the
Russia and not against one another so it
cannot be the position of the entire
government
I've always supported you and when when
you're hesitant about the things that
are not really necessary Mr far your
time is running out well thank you very
much for the question let me quite clear
the principles are as I have described
them and yes the decision that we have
just taken is a decision where many
citizens are worried and I tried to say
that initially please trust the
government please trust me we will
continue to resist the pressure and Loud
clamoring we will make decisions that
are well reasoned and that are part and
parcel of the decisions they're taken by
our partners and allies and decisions
that can be justified and and not in any
other way we are not talking about a
fighter planes I've already made that
clear and we talked about flight bans
over Ukraine
the two we will not be part and parcel
of that and that will not change
and we will not send any ground trips I
said there will not be any direct
participation of NATO troops in this war
it hasn't been the case so far it will
not be the case in future that is
something we said right from the
beginning not just me but also the U.S
president said it and so that should be
taken as fit we have a follow-on
question
not I move on
from CDO CSU Dr Matthias willebec
Madam president Chancellor let's change
the subject matter
we want to talk about The credibility of
the chancellor in the case of the verb
work Bank
there are now minutes
made available minutes that were
confidential and these minutes
are talking about a statement that you
made in 2020 before the financial
committee regarding a varberg
foreign
you recalled that you confirmed that the
meeting took place and you also
confirmed that you had no preparation
for this meeting and you also confirmed
that
it was about
um what the public prosecutor said so
when it comes to the conversation with
Mr olyaris under a three further
question that you had with Mr oliarius
can you recall these conversations I
want to say that there have already been
many questions regarding that many
others have been given and the various
authorities have been questioned
there's no truth in um
thinking that we
put some pressure and because of that I
was very happy with the confidential
minutes now being made available
well you have not really answered the
question
okay so let me continue
well
um you had four con conversations in
that period over 15 months four
conversations with Mr oliaris three
times uh where you met in person where
you had about an hour together when you
were still mayor of Hamburg and then
again
foreign